well there's five boroughs and it feels
almost impossible to experience
everything that the city has to offer
but that didn't stop us from trying one
burrow at a time
i met up with my new bestie i am not
kidding fat joe
who's such a good human oh my god i see
why everybody worships him and he took
me on a tour of his native borough
the bronx let's take a look
hey everyone we're here in the bronx
with the grammy-nominated musician
entrepreneur and bronx native and he is
about to take us on the ultimate bronx
tour i just can't wait to meet him and
i'm actually going to meet him right now
welcome to the bronx bad job
[Applause]
i think i'm going to record this show
and play that intro back every morning
for motivation where are we going first
this is the number one italian bakery in
the bronx let's go
i'm so excited
[Music]
oh wow there's cookies with our faces on
it
shout out to the staff about two so's
oh my gosh yeah yeah yeah that's the
biggest one that's called a canoli
believe it or not they specialize in all
desserts the favorite thing of mine here
is birthday cakes do we get to try the
birthday cake big time
oh
my gosh that is this is beautiful home
is where you are wow
you've been married 26 years 26 years
yeah
it's been real joe give me a word of
wisdom about longevity and marriage when
you meet the person you love a switch
goes off where you say
this is it
because i had no money when i met her i
lived in an apartment and i only had a
mattress and so we made the pass i said
listen if we get successful we're never
gonna leave each other we're never gonna
change on each other joe there are so
many things i want to keep talking to
you about let's go to the next location
and we'll pick another profound dope
subject this guy is amazing we're going
to jimmy spa con sofrito to give you
that real authentic porter you can't you
can't get really than this
[Music]
jimmy is a living legend he make these
recipes and mix things up that no one
would ever think of in the latin
community now this is some culture it's
a
meat and starches and root vegetables i
am so excited okay here we go you guys
this is my very first time
[Music]
how does that thing not stop
you know this is the best i've been
collecting sneakers my whole life for 20
something years and so we're about to go
to my newest store that hasn't even
we're going to reveal it on your show
it's called nyc the bronx
and uh let's get going over there break
out the kliq lights we have a premiere
coming let's go
voila
after you
so this is the latest creation up nyc
the third store we're in the south bronx
we wanted to do something really really
beautiful for the community you know a
lot of people
who get successful whether they're
famous or they're entrepreneurs the
dream is to leave the hood and most of
them never come back
the thing that i like is we create a hub
a safe place for the community showing
that the future entrepreneurs are
successful people that come from the
hood you can be successful move out but
you could come back and just give
inspiration and give hope i am really
like just insanely overly impressed let
me show you this room over here we have
a learning center for kids that don't
have access to computers that i'm gonna
have my successful friends come
once a month and give them a a
motivational for the kids and the
project's right across the street so let
me let me show you so you can see that
this is real
[Music]
this is the projects affordable housing
across the street it's time that people
take our community serious and invest
back
and show them the love that they need
and the support they need what do you
think
attributes the most
to being such a good person i just we've
been through so much in life that we
have no choice but god has blessed me
and my family but to give back to my
community and just offer them hope or
inspiration if i got something for you
that's jupiter
[Music]
thank you we love you too
i'm beloved y'all
these are some dunks called new york
versus new york all the street
basketball parks are down here
it's just a gift from us to you you know
up nyc you know because we love you and
we thank you appreciate you for all the
love you're showing us this is such a
big deal that i'm gonna get a pair of
sneakers from you right now like
i mean i just can't it's like we're in
england and i'm being knighted by the
queen i mean you've definitely been
knighted in the bronx
thank you for literally making me
the coolest person amongst my friends
what do you think those are flat and
they match i'm gonna do
oh
man
oh joe i love you so much i love you so
much
and uh that joe he hooked us up with
some cool sneakers so we thought we'd do
the same for all of you i mean i have
sneakers from fat joe you i have so much
cred now it's not even funny all right
so everyone in our studio audience is
gonna get a pair of vessy shoes
what's really cool about these is
they're 100 waterproof ooh that's sexy
in this city um and vegan which is also
so good
and also
let's face facts i didn't wear these
shoes on a borough tour if you're gonna
walk around new york do yourself a favor
wear something doable comfortable and
stylish
and go to any neighborhood that you want
and enjoy yourself
[Music]